I cannot imagine the path of becoming
your very best in this limited time
without having somebody in your life
that is as unbiased as they possibly can
to commit to seeing you supporting you
and challenging you and that's their job
I'm describing what I would consider to
be a great psychologist somebody in your
life that commits is a radical
accelerate you can do it on your
own it's harder mhm one of the dangers
in life is thinking that I need someone
to act or do something for me to be okay
so one of the great insights is to not
have the other person love me but
actually for me to give love to others
we become powerful when we know how we
want to be in life and relationship with
others and we're not dependent on the
other person being just right or just so